[Music]
hey what's up mkbhd here and what a day
to be a video creator in a studio also
if you're wondering about this shirt you
can get it at shop.mkbhd.com but also if
you want to try your hand at a free one
well currently the biggest tech giveaway
of all time is going on right now a
collaboration with me mr who's the boss
and dbrand there's literally dozens of
iphones and galaxy s 22 ultras and ps5s
and nintendo switches and more and there
are some shirts in there with all that
tech too link below if you want to enter
so today apple announced a bunch of new
stuff some of which is kind of boring
but some of which is really interesting
here so the beginning of the event was
pretty chill they dropped an apple tv
plus announcement with some exclusive
friday night baseball games meh i don't
really watch that much baseball so yeah
kind of boring then they drop some new
colorways for the iphone 13 so there's a
new solid green 13 and uh alpine green
13 pro so that's fine you know they
already have a red so they couldn't add
that as the mid-cycle refresh but green
cool got it and then we got the iphone
se refresh that we were all expecting
this is the budget iphone and apple
absolutely followed the same formula
they typically do so they put the new
chip in here it's the same a15 bionic
that's in the iphone 13
and in the old body which in this case
is still the iphone 8. they also give it
5g sub 6 only so no millimeter wave and
that's it
so that's that's the iphone se i mean
they did so the new chip gives it a deep
fusion gives it hdr4 gives it the new
photographic styles and they did also
throw in a slightly larger battery so
that's all good but
no surprises at all here it's kind of
funny the se and iphone sc used to well
it stands for special edition
but honestly this is the most formulaic
boring non-special phone that apple
makes and then the price they dropped is
actually slightly higher than last year
it's 429 instead of 399. still probably
one of the best budget phones in its
general class that's giving you the best
performance and one of the best cameras
so i'll probably still review it if you
guys are interested there's a lot of
competition at that price so it won't be
easy to win it but that's the iphone se
and then the ipad air also got an update
same body and design as before but now
there's an m1 chip inside now apple's
been way ahead in the tablet performance
and packaging for a while and this is
just another example of that this will
be an absurdly fast chip the fastest in
any tablet and it's in the package of an
ipad air now for 5.99 plus they also
updated the selfie camera to the 12
megapixel ultra wide with center stage
it also gets 5g and it's got a
thunderbolt port now because of m1 and
it added a new blue color as far as i
can tell that's that's it everything
else is the same same battery same
display same fingerprint reader same
design
all that and they mentioned they wanted
to keep making steps forward on their
commitment to the environment so they're
using recycled design i mean sorry
recycled aluminum recycled aluminum in
this thing um i'm still mad they haven't
added final cut pro to the ipad yet this
thing is so powerful
and still i mean imovie is fine but like
come on add final cut pro cowards but
then we got to the real meat of the
presentation the unveiling of the new
mac studio with m1 ultra chip and a new
studio display now this
this is interesting to me not just
because we have a youtube channel called
the studio
make sure you get subscribed to that and
not just because the studio dog's name
is mac so we already have a studio mac
but yeah this particular machine feels
so perfectly targeted it's clearly built
for someone like me oh are you a
creative professional
in a studio
okay so yeah this is this is for you
you've got my attention so this all
starts with the new chip that's inside
that they announced which is called the
m1
ultra
so basically you can think of this
as two m1 max chips fused together i
mean technically speaking that's not
that far off so a single m1 max by
itself that chip in the highest end
macbook pro that's already crushing was
the largest and most powerful chip apple
ever made this m1 ultra i guess shout
out to samsung for the ultra name
behaves like a single
massive chip literally 2.5 terabytes per
second of bandwidth between the two
halves of the chip and then 800 gigs per
second of memory bandwidth for the whole
combined thing but the whole thing has
64 or 128 gigs of unified memory it has
a 20 core cpu with 16 of those being
high performance cores for high
efficiency and with a 48 core or 64 core
gpu so that's good stuff that's good
stuff it's the new
biggest most powerful chip apple's ever
made that lives at the top of their
lineup and the only machine that they
announce that will have this new m1
ultra chip inside it is the new mac
studio so this thing is uh it's in the
shape of a mac mini if the mac mini ate
a lot of extra maybe it ate another mac
mini i don't know basically it's roughly
the same 7x7 footprint but it's much
thicker it's a whole 3.7 inches tall so
still small enough to fit under most
monitors but if you have a ruler or
something or if you happen to know
exactly how big 3.7 inches is you know
you can see that's pretty tall and can
fit on most desks but honestly this is a
fascinating design basically it has all
these perforations at the bottom where
it's sucking in fresh cold air and then
basically half the internal volume of
this thing is for cooling there's a
bunch of fans in the top and it's
pushing that hot exhaust air out of the
top half of the back of it now i'm no
expert but i'm just looking at the thing
and it looks like it has enough cooling
but also it worries me just a little bit
just a little bit because it reminds me
kinda
of the old
trashcan mac pro so you remember that
thing also had the cool air coming in
the bottom all the components in the
middle and then the cooling out the fans
at the top but i'm thinking apple's
learned their lesson from that machine
especially because now this is after all
their own silicon instead of hot intel
chip and
huge dedicated gpu but yeah i'm just
saying that's a lot of power in a pretty
compact
box basically but then last but not
least there's the new studio display so
they dropped a 27-inch 5k display that
looks like a junior version of the pro
display xdr just minus the whole xdr
thing basically so it's got a couple
different stand adjustments and i'll get
to the pricing of all the stuff in a
second it has a nano texture glass
option and there's a webcam and speakers
in there the webcam is familiar once
again it's a 12 megapixel ultrawide
camera with center stage built in a
triple mic array and a six speaker setup
that supports dolby atmos and spatial
audio so okay for my take so on the chip
i am very impressed i mean i definitely
want to get it in here in our studio and
do our benchmarking and testing because
apple did show a bunch of graphs again
as they usually do but they cycled
through them very quickly and a lot of
them weren't super useful but it
basically looked like they did most of
their comparisons against the old imac
pro which is no longer on their site
anymore rip and then against the current
intel mac pro tower
which you still can technically buy but
definitely shouldn't so on paper they're
just going to brag about performance per
watt right so they're saying it uses
less power than this core i5
and better cpu performance than a core
i9 12 900 k at the same power
consumption and it can deliver the same
performance at 100 watts less power
which is great for everybody's
electricity bill and for thermals and
then of course they're saying it'll take
way less power than an rtx 3060 ti and
can take 200 watts less power than an
rtx 3090 while delivering the same
performance which sounds absolutely sick
but i'm gonna be testing that for myself
we gotta see so we'll have those
machines in here sooner or later and
make sure you get subscribed to see
those videos when they come out but then
as far as the max studio itself
i'm very tempted or i should say i'm
interested
uh so this machine actually starts with
the m1 max in it and that one starts at
two thousand dollars but then they'll
ship you the m1 ultra max studio that
starts at four thousand dollars and that
one has two thunderbolt ports on the
front by the way instead of the two usbc
if you get the m1 max and on apple's
site you can spec it up to the 64 core
gpu for a thousand bucks you can double
that unified memory for 800 bucks and
you can go up to eight terabytes of
storage for a total max of eight
thousand dollars which isn't actually
that crazy but my main question
and i tweeted this during the event is
basically is this a mac mini pro
or
is it a mac pro
mini
and that's a real
there's a real difference and that
actually matters because if this new
machine this mac studio outperforms the
literal highest end 28 core mac pro then
is this the end of the road is this the
highest end machine that apple now needs
to make to complete the transition of
all the macs this will basically make it
the new mac pro just happens to be small
enough to fit on your desk but is
totally capable of running a whole
studio or even doing things that the
current mac pro isn't doing it has
double the media engine so it can now
play back 18 streams of 8k prores 422
video like how could you possibly need
more than that i'm looking at our i'm
looking at the the intel mac pros over
here with the
28 chord xeon chip and
768 gigs of ram and the vega 2 gpu and
i'm like that
that got to end of life pretty quickly
it was pretty expensive
but
john turnes did say something at the
very end of the presentation together
with the studio display these products
will empower users to create the studios
of their dreams and to continue to
change the world
and they join the rest of our incredible
mac lineup with apple silicon making our
transition nearly complete with just one
more product to go mac pro but that is
for another day now back to tim
uh and see that that actually answers
the question see it's not a mac pro mini
it's a mac mini pro it's a it's a small
desktop computer that sits right on your
desk on your mouse pad just like that
and costs a tenth of the price of the
big dog and just happens to be
just as capable if not more capable
because of the architecture but yeah
it's it's clearly not the end of the
line and there's still
one more like there's a reason there's
still a bunch of mac pro towers behind
them in their labs and they're not all
replaced with mac studios the tower form
factor can still unlock the very highest
end of power and modularity and what the
mac is capable of so that'll have i
guess a new chip we haven't even heard
about yet and
that's the one i'm going to keep waiting
for although
clearly the new mac studio maxed out
should be totally capable of handling
everything we do here in this studio now
the studio display stan included starts
at 15.99 it's an extra 300 for the nano
texture coating and an extra 400 to make
that stand height adjustable which is
kind of crazy now there is a lot of talk
about whether or not this is actually a
good price for this monitor overall
and i think the reason that's actually
kind of hard to answer is there isn't
really any other monitor
out that's exactly like it so the way i
kind of look at it it's like they it's
if they took a 27-inch imac display and
just popped the display out
exact same panel same brightness same
resolution same size and then just
repackaged it and put a bunch of apple
features around it so i mentioned the
webcam with center stage you know other
monitors have webcams and mics but not
quite like this you know other monitors
have speakers too but if the macbook pro
speakers are anything to go by then
these are probably pretty unique as well
and then the monitor has a whole a13
bionic chip inside just to act as a
super high powered image signal
processor for that webcam to do noise
cancellation on the microphones and for
your three usb-c ports and one
thunderbolt port around the back
basically this is like everything the lg
5k ultra fine monitor ever wanted to be
except that thing came out six years ago
had basically the same specs but this is
a much cleaner packaged much better
looking you know first party version so
i think if that's what you're looking
for
it's still pricey but it is pretty
unique in that way you know it's not hdr
it's not higher fresh rate there's lots
of things that it isn't but you know
it'll pair well with basically any mac
and that's what it does well that makes
it so good but so that that's it there
you have it those are my reactions
honestly get subscribed to this channel
if you want to see the evaluations in
the machines as they come in and get
subscribed to the studio channel if you
want to see my reactions to the events
sort of in real time and as we evaluate
them when they show up here those videos
are always really fun either way that's
been it
thanks for watching
catch you guys soon
peace
[Music]